okay we were talking about this a couple
of minutes ago the weather's sort of
improving if we can get the wind to go
away but you might be thinking it's time
to take a hike Sherry but you got to be
safe be warned Red Rock has been
tweeting out that
snakes were spotted at their Visitors
Center Laura negretti is on the lookout
she joins us live from out at Red Rock
with the Rattler report and I'm assuming
those snakes were outside the visitor
center not inside the visitor center
right Lauren yeah right right right
right yeah and first off Sherry oh my
gosh I'm feeling that wind my photoc
Stacy has his hood up I've got a hand
warmer it is chilly this morning that is
for sure but yes we are in the thick of
rattlesnake season according to the
Nevada Department of Wildlife they kind
of come out in the heat March through
October time and you know just like us
they escape the heat by going to the
shade out here it that means Rock
crevices and sand Red Rock Canyon staff
offer a few tips on the trails here be
aware of your surroundings never put
your hands in feet places where you
cannot see if you see a snake leave it
alone and if you are hiking with your
pup keep it on the leash and on the
trail with you look into some
rattlesnake avoidance classes for your
dog there's a few nearby trainers in the
Vegas area and a general rule of thumb
as you are out here and as we finally
get that warm up staff do say you know
be prepared bring plenty of water wear
the right clothing and shoes and be
aware that there are some spotty cell
service out here live out near Red Rock
Laura negretti 8 News Now